hi I'm Eric Boston it man in the wasp is
full of tiny fascinating details that
you might have missed guess the little
stuff is what these chapters of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are all about
after all
so let us rewatch this movie scene by
scene and explain all the little Easter
eggs and some possible clues for
Avengers 4 and real quick before I begin
this video was brought to you by
Squarespace whether you need a domain
website or online store make it with
Squarespace more details on that later
spoiler warning if you haven't seen
ant-man in the wasp yet and let's get
started this movie opens in a similar
way to the first day at man with a
flashback that shows off Marvel Studios
impressive D aging technology joining
Michael Douglas as a young Hank Pym is
Michelle Pfeiffer as young Janet Van
Dyne the original wasp and let's not
forget the DEA gene on Evangeline Lilly
as young hope like crap what a time to
be alive Janet tells her daughter not to
worry about missing out on the mission
saying that it's so boring I'll put her
to sleep now Janet smocks news here
could be foreshadowing the sort of coma
that her character disappears into
during her 30-year absence in the
quantum realm the opening sequence also
flashes back to the scene from the first
ant man showing Hank and Janet's
takedown of the rogue ICBM the moment
Janet disappeared in the quantum realm
we also see the clip of Scott's journey
into in return from the quantum realm in
the first stamp man remember there was a
missable image of Janet's outline and
now this movie digs more into that
connection between Janet and Scott next
the movie jumps to the present day now
this actually answers some of the
questions we had about when ant-man in
the wasp fits in with in the MCU
timeline movie takes place after the
events of Captain America Civil War
because that's the event that Scott is
still dealing with the fallout over this
movie's events take place over roughly
three days ending some time before
Avengers infinity war this movie's
mid-credits scene ties things in with
the end of infinity war with Hank and
Janet hope fading away from Thanos has
snapped presumably it would have taken
some time to build a quantum tunnel and
Luis's van but we can probably place his
events around mid 2018 which is roughly
present-day Scott and Cassie have built
some play tunnels in Scotts house so
that they can have adventures while he's
on house arrest they crawled through a
laser field made of yarn which could be
a nod to ant-man's comic ant-man second
chance man and the pretend treasure is
this world's greatest grandma trophy
which is later revealed as Scott's
hiding
for the ant-man suit that he's stolen
sub war Lewis returns played by Michael
Pena who's one of the best parts of this
movie notice how as he prepares for his
big business deal he repeats I'm the
boss I'm the boss I'm the boss this is a
callback to Civil War when Scott
repeated this mantra before becoming
giant man the boss gots ankle tracker
being outside the fence triggers the FBI
led by Jimmy woo played by Randall Park
now Jimmy was a character with a long
history in the Marvel comics originally
a secret agent the 50s searching for the
yellow claw a detail that did not age
well but woo was reintroduced later as a
SHIELD agent and most recently as a
leader of an Xavier type school for
young Panem Asian mutants in Mumbai the
characters MCU backstory is that he was
a SHIELD agent who was recruited by the
FBI sidestepping that whole Hydra
conspiracy that took over most members
of shield that we saw on the TV series
when Wu explains to Cassie why her dad
is in trouble he cites these sokovia
accords that was the legislation at the
heart of the debate and civil war scott
complains that he had to learn magic to
combat his boredom under house arrest
this except this one recurring gag
throughout the movie with scott's
trickery as ant-man
being seen it's a sleight of hand magic
trick meanwhile observers seem more
impressed by scott's card tricks then
his powers as ant-man from here we see a
montage set to the theme for the
Partridge Family come on get happy as
Scott tries to cheer himself up we see
his electronic drum kit which could be a
nod to Scott and Cassie's drum set in
the comic ant-man second chance man also
there's a fun Easter egg here if you
look closely at the online close-up
magic University website one of the
course categories is micro magic the
book that Scott sobs all reading is The
Fault in Our Stars by John Green and
later Scott watches this scene from the
movie Animal House one tiny atom in my
fingernail could be one little tiny
uterus that's of course parallels this
movie's explanation of the quantum realm
in which going subatomic opens up its
own microscopic universe Scott's
bathtime dream again flashes back to his
trip into the quantum realm in the first
movie and now we see Janet's eyes
watching over him establishing the
quantum entanglement between the
characters this whole hide-and-seek
memory foreshadows the present day
seeking among the family members Janet
finds hope in the memory and later Hank
will find Janet in a
constructed version of their house in
the quantum realm Scot awakens in hopes
van outside the window appears a giant
eye of a pigeon really the van is
shrunken down this feels like a nod to
Jurassic Park when the t-rex eye appears
outside the truck window and later in
this movie we actually hear the line
clever girl which could be another nod
to Jurassic park's classic line God is
still in his bathrobe here and he
actually spends most of the movie in the
bathrobe Paul Rudd joked that this kind
of parallels the dude in The Big
Lebowski hope takes Scott to their lab
and if you look closely throughout the
lab you can see that it's being powered
by a giant Duracell battery can also see
pieces of an erector set and clothes
pins the production designers also used
blown up LEGO pieces and paperclips and
auto engine coils to give this lab a
piece together design the director one
two set apart Hank pins technology from
Tony Stark's super expensive technology
these guys are scrappier this whole toys
used as tech production design also
plays into Hank and hopes car collection
which they keep in a vintage Hot Wheels
storage case Hanks shrinks his lab
building into a rollaway luggage and
they're off to meet with Sonny birch
played by Walton Goggins Sonny birch is
a character from the Marvel Comics
better known as a corporate villain to
Tony Stark he's an associate of Obadiah
Stane and he works for Kross
technologies which was actually the
company of Darren cross in the first
movie this movie version of birch calls
quantum technology a gold rush and that
he works for some very dangerous people
now it's never revealed who those
employers are perhaps we could see a
return of Justin Hammer the arms dealer
from Iron Man 2 whose weaponry has
appeared in the Marvel Netflix series or
maybe Oscorp Norman Osborn's weapon
technology company with spider-man
partly connected to the MCU now one
theory is posed that Oscorp could take
over stark tower in Manhattan now that
Stark has moved Avengers headquarters
outside the city I know you think the
dangerous people behind verge could be
in the comments below when the deal with
birch goes south hope takes down the
guys as the wasp finally showing the
title hero in action according to Kevin
Feige this was a full-circle moment
considering the wasp was a legacy
character in the Marvel Comics having
appeared on the cover of Avengers number
1 this movie's director Peyton Reed
explained all the visual effects that
went into this sequence the ripple
design of the shrinking and growing in
these movies is called disco trails that
look is intended to reflect the art in
the
comics which tend to convey resizing in
one panel with a sort of ripple trail
the notice these dots what she saw on
the trailer of wasp dodging and running
along the throne kitchen knives now and
my breakdown of those trailers earlier
this year I pointed out what wine I
should say about how fast this thug
would have to throw three kitchen knives
at perfect succession like this well
check out his arm right after the first
throw they had to digitally animate his
arm going down to suggest that he would
have time to reach over and grab the
next knife so the effects team actually
put fought under the logistics of the
stunt and this genius at work withdraws
this question also notice during the
sequence how often the camera cuts to a
close-up of attentively Lily reacting to
the threats in this movie they designed
washes helmet to better reveal the
actors eyes and facial expressions to
more fully convey the emotions
throughout these sequences they actually
shot each action sequence an additional
take in a separate close-up setup they
called the array solely for the purpose
of capturing these reactions they also
put a lot of thought into the physics of
wasps gymnastics notice how she skids
along the spilled grains of salt the
same way an Olympic skater would skid
along the ice the animators also
granulated the flower as it billowed in
a cloud behind the wasps the way it
would appear in macro photography the
wasps escaped with the tech component is
interrupted by the ghost
now ghost is another character from the
Marvel Comics more commonly associated
with Ironman the character here is Avis
Starr played by Hannah John Kaman he may
recognize her from season six the Game
of Thrones and a few episodes of Black
Mirror Steven Spielberg actually
recommended her personally for this
movie after working with her and ready
player one Scott Hope and Hank retreat
to the office of ex-con the security
company run by Scott Lewis along with
our buddies Dave and Kurt with Ti and
David dust mal chin reprising their
roles from the first movie ex-con is
based on ant-man security solutions the
security consulting company from the
comics and Curt describes ghost as
baba-yaga
which is a supernatural boogeyman woman
from Reston folklore a version of Baba
Yaga actually appeared in the Marvel
comics at one point though pretty much
every character from folklore mythology
shows up in some form in these comics
Scott hope and Hank head over to a
university disguised with hats and
sunglasses
Scott mocks the effectiveness of these
disguises saying we look like ourselves
at a baseball game this is kind of a
meta reference to Steve Rogers and
Natasha
romanov in Captain America Winter
Soldier who went incognito and public
wearing only hats and glasses they made
up with Hank Pimm's former shield
colleague dr. bill Foster
played by Laurence Fishburne aka
Morpheus from the matrix you look
closely the set designers included a
little Easter Egg shout out to
Lawrence's past movie on the equations
on the chalkboard you listen closely to
Foster's lecture you may have heard him
say the line the object will be in an
out-of-phase in multiple parallel
realities in this movie we learn how the
quantum realm can cause phase shifting
with molecules separating causing
objects to split into various phases the
idea that objects could exist in
multiple parallel realities opens up
huge implications for the MCU
for example if Scott in the quantum
realm can phase shift into a separate
parallel reality that could be one way
he could venture out of the quantum
realm perhaps in that parallel reality
events will have gone down differently
like different Avengers could have
survived the Annis is stopped altogether
there's a lot to think about here we'll
just have to wait and see in the next
Avengers movie how important this
seemingly throwaway line into being in
Foster's office he mentions working on a
project called Goliath now in the Marvel
Comics Bill Foster often teams up with
ant-man in the Avengers as Goliath or
black Goliath another part of history
that doesn't age too well he actually
plays a major role in the Civil War
comic storyline and as appearance now
and then see you was teased by a line
from Tony Stark all the way back an Iron
Man to tap the Oracle grid and ship
stuff out of storage everything from
projects Pegasus Exodus and Goliath
Jimmy woo tracks Scott here and he's
joined by Birch's secret FBI informant
this guy's name is Jeffrey Ballard which
is actually another name from Marvel
Comics Ballard is a government official
who later works with mystique as an
enemy to Goliath known as Centurion
Scott having to retrieve the trophy from
Cassie's school while his suits resizer
is malfunctioning it's one of the
funniest sequences in the MCU there's
actually a little Easter egg on the
chalkboard during this and one of the
grammar sentences you can see the phrase
ants grow of course appearing right
behind this ant who's having issues with
his ability to crow the refractor in the
old suit leads them to the lab where it
goes sustained revealed to be Foster's
house while sneaking around this place
Scott jumps at the sight of ghosts huge
suit which just turns out to be empty
and this is probably where Scott got his
inspiration for the later trick on Jimmy
one FBI fooling them with a
giant empty ant-man suit here Ava and
foster reveal her backstory as the
daughter of shield scientist Elias star
in the Marvel Comics Elias star is the
name of the egghead which is one of the
few villains - ant-man and he's pretty
goofy this movie confirmed the nod by
making Ava's father bald though a little
less egg-shaped also in the flashback we
see a young version of Bill Foster
though they didn't need the miraculous
de-aging effect here they've just
brought in Fishburne's real life son
Langston Fishburne to play the role here
jumping ahead a little birch puts Lewis
and the others under a truth serum lazy
- another hilarious Louie's storytelling
montage I first met Scott even so by Dee
and I was like I'm police and he says
I'm Scottie and we're gonna be besties
tangents into is grandma having a
jukebox that plays only more see songs
make sure I get a callback to this later
when Louise calls Scott cellphone if you
listen closely it plays the Morrissey
song every day is like Sunday meanwhile
in Hanks lab they hit a breakthrough
with a quantum tunnel with Janet taking
control of Scott's body I love Paul
Rudd's acting here along with the
wordplay
Janet's link with Scott is called an
antenna like the antenna of an ant ant
[Applause]
and as they prepare to send Hank down in
the quantum realm they plan to track
Janet's location using a quantum
spectrometer we've actually heard it's
super nerdy device mission before in the
first Avengers when Bruce Banner used it
to track down the tesseract
how many spectrometers you have access
to all every lab you know tell them to
put the spectrometers on the roof and
calibrate them for gamma rays back at
Scott's house he chats with his daughter
Cassie who wants to be a sidekick
actually in the Marvel comics Cassie
Lang does follow her dad's footsteps
later becoming the hero stinger also
known as stature in the Young Avengers
comics rumor has it that they cast a 16
year old actress as Cassie Lang in
Avengers 4 implying one that we could
see stature in the movie and two the
debentures 4 will feature some kind of
time jump several years into the future
after the FBI arrests hang in Pope Scott
breaks them out using ants to cover
security camera which is actually a call
back to the tactic in the first ant-man
as they prepare to steal back to lab
Louie's shows up in his van and
references that old Budweiser commercial
and after beating ghosts sunny shows up
leading to this amazing street chase now
staging a car chase throughout the hilly
streets of San Francisco it's an homage
to the iconic San Francisco Street
chases in the Steve McQueen classic
Bullitt the famous lombard street makes
a cameo that's the windy crooked street
that tends to show up in a lot of movies
set in San Francisco including Pixar's
inside out and there's just a ton of
great sight gags in the sequence
including a resized Hello Kitty PEZ
dispenser ant-man using the truck as a
push cart and this movie Stan Lee cameo
when his car gets wiped out and equips
the 60s were great but now I'm paying
for it he's referring to his creation of
many of these characters in the 1960s
when it was said the whole trippin arts
and character designs drugs and that now
all this crazy cap is being made into
big-budget movies while all this goes
down Hank uses the quantum tunnel and
his vessel to explore the quantum realm
on his way down he runs into these tiny
creatures now these are called
tardigrades also known as water bears
tardigrades are micro animals but they
aren't this small they're actually only
half a millimetre long and kind of
visible to the human eye though easier
with microscopes so they're bigger than
cells not like these subatomic beings
floating in quantum space like this he
eventually finds Janet who doesn't give
much of an explanation of how she
survived these thirty years it appears
like she turned one of her suits wings
into kind of a spear
perhaps for hunting her self-defense
still what the hell did she eat
tardigrade meat Janet does tell Hank
this cryptic line this place changes you
in ways you can't imagine adaptation as
part of it but it's more evolution now
it seems like Janet is suggesting the
quantum realm caused her to evolve
giving her a kind of telepathy and
healing energy maybe she used it to heal
her own starvation but it's interesting
that Janet uses the word evolution in
the Marvel world evolution is more
commonly used in connection to the x-men
who derived their powers from the mutant
gene and evolutionary trait now in the
past the MCU has had to be a lot more
careful about using the term mutant or
really any x-men terminology because all
those characters and ideas were property
of Fox but now that this merger between
Disney and Fox looks like it's going
forward this could be an early step to
open the door to mutants in the MCU
either way Peyton Reed teased that there
were some key clues hidden
the quantum realm in this movie to hint
at future MCU plot points the way that
the wasp was hidden the quantum imagery
of the first amen they're not gonna be
easy to find we may have to wait until
the blu-ray comes out to see everything
in high-definition
but but but I wasn't able to make this
out a moment Hank and Janet sighs out of
the quantum realm they passed by
something that looks a lot like some
kind of city the quantum realm is based
partially on a micro verse from the
Marvel comics which does contain planets
and civilizations that ant-man and other
characters like Doctor Doom in the
Fantastic Four interact with now this
place that we see in the shot is some
kind of civilization and not just that
trick of a lighter amorphous shapes and
colors that could explain how Janet Van
Dyne survives so long and gives Scott
Lang a potential place to go as he waits
for his next steps while stranded in the
quantum realm meanwhile back on the
surface ant-man chases Sonny to the
ferry now the very tour guide is a cameo
by comedian Tim Heidecker of Tim and
Eric ant-man and the wasps working title
was cherry blue which is a reference to
a Tim and Eric sketch Scott names the
flying ant who carries him ant so Neo
Banderas a callback to the nickname for
the other ant that he had ulysses s
grant and as he blows up back the giant
man he gets light-headed and dizzy since
being big requires a ton of energy he
also describes the air as chunky at some
point now he's referring to the higher
concentration of water vapor in the air
which when consumed by bigger gasps at
that size it's harder for his lungs to
inhale at all
Cassie watches all this go down on the
news where the on screen Chiron labels
him as giant man giant man is a
character's name when he's giant size
because in the comics it's kind of a
separate hero from ant-man but this year
is the first time in the movies the term
giant man is actually listed Janet and
Hank returned to the surface Janet heals
Ava and Scott beats the FBI back home
getting his ankle tracker removed and he
wonders what it's like on the outside
world asking Jimmy woo do people still
dance now this could be a nod to the
guardians of the galaxy where star Lord
and Drax categorized all life forms into
ones that dance and ones who don't
sadly the beings who danced the Peter
quill Groot
Drax all got wiped away and Thanos has
snapped so sure Scott people still dance
for like a few more seconds and the
final scene shows Scott hoping Cassie
watching a movie at a drive-in screen
this is another image inspired
the ant-man second chance man coming and
the movie they're watching is them a
1954 monster movie about nuclear testing
at a government resulting in giant sized
ants terrorizing cities now for all the
details in the mid and post credits
scenes we made a couple other videos
explaining those Sam broke down what
happens in his video and in another
video we don't speculate on the meaning
of Janet Van Dyne bringing up a time
vortex and the emotional tone set by
that emergency broadcast on the TV and
how it all connects to Avengers 4 so go
watch those videos in the meantime I'll
leave you guys to the question would you
rather have ant-man get rescued from the
quantum realm by the Avengers or Captain
Marvel or someone else or should
ant-man's experience in the quantum
realm be the source of the Avengers end
game to fight back against Thanos
comment down below with your thoughts or
tweet me directly idea boss and as I
mentioned before this video was brought
to you by Squarespace if you want to set
up a super stylish website fast you can
make it with Squarespace whether it's to
set up a business or showcase some of
your creative work or a market to
quantum physicists to rescue you from
the quantum realm man I'm just saying
have you considered a sleekly designed
website Scott Lang Squarespace released
eight new templates this year that looks
so nice and you don't have to know
anything about coding or design they
take care of all of that for you just go
to Squarespace comm for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
Squarespace comm slash new rockstars to
get a 10% discount off your first
purchase you can also just click on the
link in the description below reminder
to follow new rockstars on Twitter for
updates on our videos like this video
share it around and subscribe to new
rockstar as for all of our marvel deep
dives theories and updates thanks for
watching
I got the rest of the candy bar to eat
bye
[Music]